joining us now is former Secret Service
agent Dan bungee No then even I cynical
as I am 27 years of doing this I'm a
little bit surprised by the
instantaneous response to this executive
order which I'm skeptical of in the
first place I would say but for people
who've been calling it for this for the
last week when they finally get it to
immediately attack it tells you
something really important I think it
does Tucker and I don't know why America
is still pretending that with the
radical far left we're dealing at all
with principled people I mean we know
this exact same thing on the detention
of miners who were brought across the
border illegally happened under Obama
and the intensity of the coverage Tucker
was nowhere near this so let's all stop
pretending that liberal liberals give a
damn about immigrants I'm not suggesting
all Democrats I'm telling you the
radical far left I'm looking in the
camera and telling you my experience
with these goons is they don't give a
damn about these kids what they care
about our open borders and raw voting
power that they're losing to
working-class Americans who realize what
liberals really are that's the real goal
says nothing to do with principles at
all I've got a bunch of kids if I go to
jail and I'm separated from them by
force
even if I'm convicted by the way people
who haven't been proved guilty spend a
lot of time in jail in this country well
anyone make my case for me one even weep
for me well any other cable news anchors
start crying in the middle of a
broadcast over my children do you think
no you're a Europe conservative
commentator their police stators they'll
actually celebrate throwing you in jail
without probable cause for even arrest
by the way but that's a whole other
topic on spy game we can talk about
another time but Tucker this is a pure
political play for them you have to
understand liberalism is dead it's a
vacuum they don't stand for anything
their policy platforms are not tenable
they can't put up the campaign sign that
says give us your money give us your
healthcare and let us take over the
public schools because they're doing
peachy so what do they do they have to
replace all those lost votes with fear
and replacing them with open borders and
endless people coming into the country
uncontrollably that they can use to
steal their votes through absentee
balloting voter fraud and other things
there and and tight and endless
entitlement programs they don't have a
back-up plan I think
I think you're right I remain totally
opposed to separating people from their
kids especially American citizens by the
way my views have not changed on that
dan thank you